suc on va se quitter la surprise de
maïté machine pour ceux qui n'ont pas
trop de temps finalement entre midi et
deux pour manger un petit encas comme
consistant
alors vous allez avoir droit à une
recette exceptionnelle is it une recette
que vous trouverez dans aucun livre de
cuisine ça il faut prôner pendant que
vous ne verrez pas faire cela avant que
vous ne mangerez peut-être pas très
souvent donc plus eh bien je vais faire
un hamburger rio parce qu'il va
démissionner tarillon tout à fait avec
au mieux comme on fait son match et vous
voilà amédée que faut-il pour faire
barrage
pas grand chose un petit pain de
campagne en moyenne il ya plus gros
voilà qui coupe en deux mais voilà jean
luc c'est ce qu'ils font après là dessus
j'y mets quelques petites feuilles de
salade de gésiers des la mairie magret
et du foie gras chaud et on referme le
couvercle et en mange ça traîne en
longueur qui prouve la belle santé des
ombres exactement alors montrez nous
c'est de faire venir vos foies gras mais
malgré les jets 10 avant qu'on avait
installé sur la jolie salade ça va
devoir épouser de sa maman alors vous
dix secondes et tout a bien marché c'est
pas au nom des dauphins le gras parce
que c'est bon ça nourrit sa nourrice au
monde
un écart du magret séparer d'ici là est
un joueur est gelée soir là dessus que
foie gras voilà on va dire que ce soit
nourri sa non et ça c'est pas mauvais
voilà mon petit nom là et un petit
couvercle par là dessus alors non je
vous donnais au petit déjeuner à pierrot
tous les jours
lionel il importe de faire sur son
travail
oui c'est bon maintenant vous savez je
vous ai apporté suite bordeaux concept
vieux je m'habille et va vous aussi vous
aurez le choix maintenant on est en
cours de classique traditionnelle de
modèle du genre de riez patron il se
trouve et de na li té de riom et
l'emporterait réméré pour passer une
bonne soirée pour sept centièmes de la
cuisine des mousquetaires
nous vous avons ri nous rions souvent
mais vous avez vu qualité comme faisant
la cuisine sera très bien elle rit elle
l'a c'est bien on vous en fait autant et
puis on sera toujours heureux de vous
retrouver pour d'autres émissions
nous espérons continuer longtemps en
dialogue avec vous bonsoir
à bientôt bonsoir